there were several steps along the way I
went to college at Oberlin Ohio and
after that I went to Boston and then
after a couple of years there I went to
grad school in Arizona in Tucson at the
University of Arizona and I stayed there
seven years and I met a woman who was
entering the grad program just as I was
leaving it and she was from Pakistan her
name's Ozma awesome con and we ended up
getting married and then after staying
another year in Arizona after her
graduation was she we were both eager to
go somewhere and try something different
um she had just come into the country to
go to university and then grad school so
she wasn't you know it wasn't an
immigration thing or something so we
looked around we applied for jobs
overseas we ended up going to Morocco
for three years as English teachers and
that was an interesting well my world
view of the state's has been slowly
changing over time but yes there's
nothing like leaving the country to help
you look back and see the country more
clearly and there's nothing with like
living with people who are quite
skeptical about the intentions of your
country to make you think about that
however I have to say that I've just on
a personal level both in Morocco and
then impacts on people are incredibly
friendly and hospitable and interested
and kind this idea that they're all just
raving lunatics like you see on the
cover of Newsweek it's simply not true
it's a lie it is a lie designed to make
you stay home and so yes many people
have very
strong opinions about say Israel
Palestine and they think that Israel
gets billions of dollars per year which
it does and the Palestinians get nothing
and that money is being used for
repression and so forth that's a
legitimate political opinion to have
does this mean that they walk up to me
and beat me up on the street no it does
not and and that I wish that perception
could change